so my husband left me three months ago
for his teenage secretary however the
other night he came home for some clean
underwear on a farm
you've probably already seen the
marvelous mrs. basil after ordering
books paper towels or whatever it is you
buy on Amazon Prime what are the [ __ ]
rules [ __ ] rules the [ __ ] rules a
lot has already been made about the
show's depiction of a woman in a man's
world but just as important is the
depiction of a newborn New York
counterculture that didn't want anything
to do with the state those people just
want to be left the [ __ ] alone
Mazal is the 1950s Upper West Side New
York housewife who discovers after her
husband leaves her that she has a knack
for stand-up comedy did you ever think
he was supposed to be something and and
you suddenly realize you're not yes
married the domestic life she thought
she wanted goes have been smoked with
nowhere to go
she stumbles into an East Village
theater and tells us how she feels about
it
[Applause]
they're standing up on their own quick
trigger warning here for free speech
nerds public indecency and performing
without a cabaret hey that's Lenny Bruce
he was a real 1950s comedian who was
routinely arrested for obscene jokes he
told on stage a topic he often worked
into his act if the word [ __ ]
stimulates you sexually you're in a lot
of trouble as a comedian you just wanted
to discuss taboo ideas something his
young boundary-pushing audience was into
basil is cut from the same cloth even
New Yorkers in the audience are on Mazal
side
maybe that's because they felt the
encouragement of the state all around
them and they were sick of it too
Jane Jacobs was a journalist and an
urban theorist in the 1950s who pushed
back on centrally-planned city
developments and huge looming urban
renewal projects in the series she and
her followers protest the building of a
highway through the middle of a city
park she thought city planners shouldn't
get to decide what a city should be but
rather people should be left alone to
live their lives and let those choices
determine how the community would grow
and function after her husband bails
Mazal starts walking into new worlds and
trying on new identities something she
thinks she should be allowed to do
without anyone standing in the way or
literally dragging her off stage in
Maysles day this was a newish idea what
a good one he said stuff to make a nun
blush but he didn't say in the convent
unassuming I was not any convent where's
the crime right cops that hang around
outside clubs waiting to harass
entertainers for doing that thing I hate
that passionately you start controlling
speech you slip slidin toward fascism
perhaps the most individualistic theme
in the show that nasal doesn't even fall
into the second wave feminist category
history books associated with her time
instead her brand of feminism is less
about movement and more about personal
choice she enters and exits her corseted
Upper West Side life with the loose
pot-smoking world of a downtown comedy
club whenever she sees Ben I thought you
wanted to be a cool chick I could be a
cool chick with a doorman and a kelp
native put her in refrigerator camping
midge is building her own world it
involves pearls bright red lipstick and
saying [ __ ] a lot and it's pretty [ __ ]
up to send in the cops for that the
second season of the marvelous mrs.
Mazal is starting soon let's hope midge
can stay out of jail
and that's it for me my name is mrs.
Manville thank you and good night
[Applause]